i went to hawaii with uh well let's how
about a round of applause for kalila's
here
gilbert we got jorah and um
yes we got jorah from game of thrones
here friendzo tell us why george is
jorah of the andals
because uh juror wants to [ __ ] khaleesi
khaleesi's leading him on and um jorah
will do anything risk his life for
khaleesi he's not going to get any [ __ ]
and that's what [ __ ] george is he
will debride god i bet you i bet your
money when he goes to be on the wall
mm-hmm he's going to take a little pill
he's going to pass down they're going to
steal a [ __ ]
hashtag columbia hashtag columbus when
he crosses the wall into columbia
he's going to get you guys follow me and
george's door jorah of the animals right
man up
man up let him let him play the monkey
i'm tired of your [ __ ] look sweetie
you're a [ __ ]
mahalo mahalo everybody hello hello
brother boy
what the [ __ ] is going on oh you
attacked me on my pocket i'm sorry i
love you introductions come on i'm gonna
do the introductions now okay before
before we even get into you yeah we have
to get into something even more
important okay
[Laughter]
so i'm sick i'm in my room before you
get here okay
and i look at my girlfriend like sweetie
what's going on
she turns around and she's [ __ ]
crying oh my god we have to talk
okay yeah crying yeah 10 15 minutes
later i go i go what are you crying
about you're sick again and you know
what she says george
she didn't say that yeah this piece of
[ __ ] you made her cry yeah it made her
[ __ ] cry before the podcast wow this
piece of [ __ ] i wasn't i wasn't crying
like that oh yeah yeah you were crying
it's not wait but first of all whatever
you're doing right now i don't want to
make you feel bad i'm going to make them
feel bad because you don't make my
[ __ ] girlfriend crying oh [ __ ] okay
now listen to me man
apologize
i'm sorry what did you do
what did she do baby
he
he
he did some passive aggressive stuff to
try to give me a note for the podcast
and what was it
because i i blink excessively and my
eyes dart around a lot and my eyes dart
around to the mirror when i'm trying to
look at gilbert
he wrote on the mirror we see you
and that started the whole thing where
why don't you just tell me if you want
to tell me something tell it to my face
you don't have to write it on a mirror
for me to accidentally see
just to get your point across you can
tell me i'm right here
okay
the night game
no it's not the night king what the
night king's doing no but
why did you just do that i was just
[ __ ] right i know you know why
because you were you you were smiling
when you were talking and i don't i
don't really like it you were staring
you're on george's you're on georgia
michael rosenbaum
you were looking at me like this while
she was talking yeah so you weren't even
listening to her
you were looking at me like this like
yeah
no i wasn't microsoft yeah
we're on camera dude baby look at the
camera you're both the night kings uh
i'm over it who's the knight you're a
knight all right
what was your first impression of me uh
i thought you had
no i don't want to say it yeah yeah that
was [ __ ] no down like yeah a little
bit of that [ __ ] you know what dude
but a lot
a lot of people say i know but when they
say it it really i don't know why you're
laughing george okay
because in terms of whites you're like a
two jesus that's out of a hundred that's
a lot of rights you're the worst like
you you're worthless
you want them to stay around and work
for you and he has
syndrome supreme no one is left premium
time oh man that was good i was tribal i
know but still dude it's like i'm not
feeling it bro but that's fine we got
george the whole you know what the whole
all-white thing is working out for me
and you're wearing all white i like it
oh thank you yeah it just it makes you
like a person in the room it makes you
like creepier
why do you like it when george is creepy
he's just a creepy dude he should
embrace that
you think he's creepy yeah he should
like have like a necklace with baby
shoes oh god
like murder race do your thing dude
murderous creep a vial of your own [ __ ]
so what else would you add to his outfit
to get the max creepiness you know what
a fishing hat
but with all the lures and stuff and
it's still in it yeah yeah yeah yeah and
there's a story behind each other yeah
there's a weird story if you look
closely they're not lures
they're like fingernails of other dead
ladies damn oh my goodness
the fingernails of dead ladies in your
fishing hat
that'd be cool i think i could pull that
off if you but dead ladies he didn't
kill just deadly
that's even more creepy yeah he like
exhumed bodies and then picked their old
fingernails and then made him into like
put him in
a tattoo on your chest that's of an
unfinished swastika oh god
yeah only two lines but why is it on
there's a storyboard no because is he a
racist he's not
interesting he toes the line yeah yeah
that's creepy yeah that's some creepy
[ __ ] and then he's like um
he's writing a book mineconf2
interesting part two it's not very
subtle at all yeah really get in there
it's like yeah the revenge
mineconf the revenge new wave the new
wave yeah yeah i mean i think you should
embrace your creepiness dude yeah
yeah but um i
did i just do it
and that's the key to everyone
you suck george
but you're here
do you know why
you look at me you're the worst
you have absolutely nothing but let me
say something you can get a specific
everything and everything but you showed
up
and you you were persistent
of here
no actually the royal tandem bombs over
here is the lightest guy i know i can't
sorry about that what are you selling
ice cream in 1950
with the ascot the paisley oh my god
[Laughter]
probably have some eggs
but let me say something okay what's the
scarf what's that all about today that's
new
it's a good western scarf you know it's
yeah yeah yeah yeah
western scarf yeah
paisley do you believe that women have
[ __ ] him yeah women have [ __ ] a lot
of garbage we [ __ ] everything
yeah yeah yeah yeah not that you're not
yeah yeah yeah he's not garbage but then
he's on the fence i've been talking a
lot about that on stage now i [ __ ]
uglies all the time since high school
yeah wow never discriminated
if george was sober
right right and he was in aaa whatever
and he didn't want me like i'm more like
i think he'd in like sex addiction
for touching kids right even worse it's
like eating people
yeah yeah i'm [ __ ] like limbs
right here like he would take dahmer
[ __ ] and take it to the next level yeah
like i'm not only gonna eat it i'm going
to [ __ ] it yeah yeah i mean i'm going to
[ __ ] like an opening of a torso
he puts his own special sauce on his
scarf the [ __ ] out of here bro with your
white [ __ ] [ __ ] man
sorry brother
sorry
society and then he goes into alaska
like he'll strip naked and just go into
force for a couple days and live or they
find him like years later just a
skeleton yeah
like just just skeleton around the tree
yeah hugging it who was dick inside the
tree
yeah he tried to [ __ ] the tree he got
stuck and he died you [ __ ] the tree
once i know you did george you [ __ ]
we've all [ __ ] weird [ __ ] right what's
the weirdest
my point is is that and then when she
woke up and then um and then i couldn't
sleep until like seven
p.m and then i heard you guys nasty
voices but then i kept sleeping you know
your voices are not good i'm sorry
your voices are towards your voice i'll
be honest with you i give you a hard
time all the time
about how ugly you are
you don't know how to dress
you know you're [ __ ] pussy-free
why you're pussy-free like pussy-free
diet yeah diet coke diet [ __ ] [ __ ]
and diet possibility [ __ ] that's it
george is
that [ __ ]
yes okay but we got george and we got
handsome bryce oh handsome bryce today
we got handsome bryce man
dr [ __ ] oh and that's his new [ __ ]
doctor
what's george
unfuckable oh nurse unfuckable nurse
yeah yeah not even a doctor
and we have a guest today we have um
george is sick thank god
because i don't know if i can handle him
this early in the year this early in the
year i think my prayer my christmas
prayer was just as long as he doesn't
die
yeah i don't want him to die just sick
enough but i wanted to get like sick
work to the point where he's on the
precipice of death
the doorway don't open the doorway don't
go in yeah okay okay as long as he
doesn't care i want a little suffering
diarrhea from the mouth all kinds of
stuff
a little blood but we got gilbert we got
kala and we got his handsome
wow bryce cousin so handsome the better
half
who actually has a girlfriend because
you're not because you're not gay and
you're and you're also uh
a man of uh today a relevant man he's a
renaissance
yeah any other things i think about you
know talk about georgia's betrayal well
it's i'm trying to ease into it because
i don't even know how to really do it
but um
i'm gonna be point blank with you man
get on that mic
and i'm i'm going to give you an out
well i'm going to take it then sir
oh you are okay what what's the outcome
i'll tell you about all right then i
hear you're out you can leave our
podcast you can go with theovan
why would i leave this podcast because
um atheovon's like check this out
the other night
and i go what is it and it's theo and
george interesting comfortably hanging
out arms over each other like this
hanging out and he's like yeah dude he's
my dude too now man bruh bruh and i was
just like hmm we should have signed an
exclusivity country biblical [ __ ] right
there man that's [ __ ] shakespearean
building the empire uh really creating
more family you know
bringing more people into the family let
me tell you something you [ __ ]
all right
if you
we come first
yeah
no and this is what i mean
no you're not you don't listen to what i
mean man okay
all right just kidding just kidding if
on a wednesday you're doing his podcast
and i need to shoot an emergency one you
bail his
that kind of [ __ ] we come first yeah all
right
then you can do both that wasn't such a
bad confrontation yeah i thought you
were going to go that's why that's why
i've got a cousin you know you can
always cover his back
so how long are you going to be
stretched then so you want what do you
want to do what's your you want to just
produce
podcasts
uh at the moment yeah
and wow that's cool yeah that's awesome
but
what you gain there's synergies uh
through uh through expanding the empire
you know you learn new things for
everybody you work with may i make a
comment uh oh typically you have a very
nasally voice your regular voice yeah
the fact that you're easily that you're
congested now actually takes the it
takes it away takes it away yeah so
you're not nasally when you're actually
named basically
you sound okay
you sound okay you know what you're
allowed to call me instead of text me
now only when you're sick
okay it lasts for another three days
then back to texting
yeah yeah yeah your energy is weird
you're still saying he's still sick
i met george's um
off and on on again girlfriend last
night side piece
yup i'm gonna
thank you for the permission yeah thank
you i'm [ __ ] gonna
all right
so i'm not gonna get into it but um
there's some been some tragedies we had
this shooting in um florida we're not
gonna talk about it because we don't
talk about stuff like that it's a
[ __ ] that was a disaster for our
nation but another disaster happened
george is set at the [ __ ] improv last
night
i mean what the [ __ ]
i mean
we haven't we have some footage right
we're gonna put it on we'll put it we'll
put it out somewhere on a vlog or
something but um
i taped it and i was taping it on my
phone and i think at one point gilbert
was sitting next to me what 400 seats do
you think yeah there are 400 people we
have 4 500 people on it and um i
distinctly remember going item this is
the worst that it could be and not even
joking like you were yeah it was the
worst it was freaking out george walks
off stage
and he goes
i think i did pretty good
so confident
anyway um that's that and this is uh
listen guys um
i've been thinking in my head over and
over again i've been reliving george's
set in my head
the whole week oh yeah yeah i can't stop
it it's like i was um
i mean i don't want anyone to get
offended
i you know i'm gonna reword it okay okay
it was like i was sexually assaulted by
yeah by like a celebrity
you know like you know like i was you're
me too i was me too oh gotcha yeah oh
wow i
i feel like it's something that i cannot
shake i'm gonna just tell you i feel
like i have a resentment too
i'm gonna just tell you right now that
that setup made it impossible to offend
my set at all that is without looking
there's no way to defend it um
you you owe me apology
i owe you a thank you
you owe me an apology
for
making me witness that
so i want you to say i'm sorry
thank you sir that was a great
experience all right you know what i
really are you're right now you're
grounded
you're [ __ ] grounded artistically
all right now you put the hat on go in
the corner of the room and you shut your
[ __ ] mouth wait what does that be he
can't like write jokes right now no just
for like five minutes okay okay you
don't talk for five minutes
are you harry face [ __ ] dumb
delusional pizza
all right george in a scale of one to
ten what how would you grade yourself
put your fingers up you can't talk
oh my god you know someone wrote in
wrote us an email yeah um in regards to
um i think we always talk about people
who are delusional yeah and he said that
he's a creative director and he said
that there is a term to describe
someone who thinks they did a lot better
than they actually did and it's called
the dunning-kruger effect oh yeah oh we
have a terminology yeah
if you change it again
if you change it again i'm never going
to be able to retain it in my head and
i'm going to call it the effect
phenomenon can i read it to you
tell me if this is is it an effect or
enough phenomenon
all right let's go establish that okay
and in the field of psychology the
dunning-kruger effect is a cognitive
bias wherein people of low ability
suffer from illusory superiority
mistakenly assessing their ability as
greater than it is
the cognitive bias of illusory
superiority derives from the inability
of low ability persons to recognize
their own ineptitude
that's not mean it is [ __ ]
dead-on without the self-awareness of
metacognition low-ability people cannot
objectively evaluate their actual
competence or incompetence
yeah keep playing is that it keep
playing okay so there's two types of
dunning-kruger effect it's that either
you hold yourself in such high esteem or
you hold others in low you get you have
a very low regard for others so like i
don't think it's this a ladder i think
it's the um
the first thing
with george
that he i think he's he
you're allowed to speak yeah
god damn it i was uh i was writing down
i was red set of the kids that's exactly
what we're talking about
key words low ability
i am very offended by the low ability
statement that kept on coming up every
time you described the effect can we can
we at least do this can we at least do
this okay
that i'll give you this
you went up there absolutely not only
that not only that you didn't seem
like you weren't stuttering or oh you
tried to get my head i refuse i know i
know but you you think stop
stop just let him go don't stop
you went up there and you memorized a
bunch of things
and you said those things the way you
planned to say them okay
but let's say um i was gonna go see
a um a musician like hey you coach come
on check out the singer songwriter
at you know some coffee shop which i
would never do but anyway like i said i
go
and he's up on stage and he's in a clown
outfit
and he's juggling
and he looks great he's confident
killing it he's killing it with the
juggling
but that's not what i came to see that's
not you know singing yeah what you were
doing up there was not stand-up comedy
it was some sort of weird spoken word it
was poetry it was not even no it wasn't
poetry it wasn't poetry i'll kill you
it's not poetry but you know so i'm
going to give it up to you
that there was a bunch of people there
you went up on stage like you said you
would
and you gave us a little horror
and i'm proud of you and i thank you for
your service and let's just leave it at
that you can't tell me that you killed
i wouldn't say i killed per se there's
room for improvement definitely okay and
now that i've had this experience i
think i will improve greatly okay
if there's
okay let's try okay it's like this okay
let's say i was a pool man it was an
empty pool
right and let's just say filling the
pool
filling the pool right is being
like a competent stand-up comic
okay okay
what you did and i'm not exaggerating or
lying
was me taking a visine drop and just
in the pool a dot that's the amount
here's what i think
here's what i think happened i think i
did okay but then craig craig told the
audience i did badly then you went up
and told the audience i did badly you
did say afterwards the audience was like
well he did okay i thought but these two
people have done it a lot they know a
lot more
yeah it's a different it's a different
one that we have to create
yeah jka oh gka gka
george campbell effect gk
[Laughter]
i genuinely think that you can write
you're a great writer nope
um he got chuckles
um no i i don't whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa what stop stop stop
stop now this is what i wanted to say
yeah
now stop right here what uh what he just
did right there right was he's now in
for life
gilbert right now
did something that was like
so brave
that it was so brave
and so
aragorn from lord of the rings it was
like
whoa dude you're going to fight those
like you know
those black riders oh my god
with like a torch that's what you just
did and you saved frodo
my god
what you did right there gave me a lot
of respect you're fired
no i'm kidding i'm so proud of you
george i couldn't have done that yeah
you could have oh my god
you could have done it i could have not
done it
ten times you would have done it
i uh sweetie the
ten times that i did stand up i couldn't
even get a sentence out i understand
that i'm telling you right now and i
promise you
i promise you this you would have done
better i wouldn't have okay well that's
that's right they're not a factual thing
everyone listening to right now all
right we're now on a george kimmel like
support group
all right my name is bobby i'm a
george kimmel addict what the the
difference with me is aka the gk yeah
gka
i wouldn't have walked out of there and
said that was pretty good i would have
been like oh my god i ate it yeah i
can't even he doesn't have the i ate it
jeans yeah you don't have it you don't
have it because i'm going to tell you
this right now
even at
your how long you've been doing it
uh i haven't been doing it seriously
because i dedicate my life to this but
uh
and we thank you for your service
bi-weekly
for a couple years he also works for
every other person
but anyway
[Laughter]
i mean you're like stretching yourself
then but anyway um
let me say this okay if i had the
if i had that response with that many
people
i literally would have walked off stage
and asked
any opener anyone that i opened for
it would have been precipice i'd be on
the precipice of suicide oh my god oh my
god don't put that in his head no i'm
not i'm not that's you you're you're
healthier than i am
you're healthier than i'm just telling
you me
is i just have the opposite
ear effect
where if i
everything that i do
is shitty
everything yeah yeah like this weekend i
did the houston improv
there was only one show and asked sandy
i walked off i got that was good
i was in the i was in the zone
you know i improvised i was good every
retort was perfect everything was good
and um
yep matter of fact the show before
you went on
he came to the green room when he was in
irvine and he was like that was the
worst show i've ever done in my life
told us that yeah i cannot i have a good
ear and that you need that
if if you would have said
wow
i mean i did everything that i said i
would do but that wasn't the response
wasn't what i expected i'd be like there
we go
that's what i want
but i don't want to hear
oh yeah that was pretty good i could
have done better but no
because this is this is the
comedy is not this is the green berets
you know you want to be able to do all
the exercises you want to be able to do
all the things
so that in combat you're ready
i'm still proud of you george reporter
i'm kind of not
i'm kind of not
but you know you you really just ruined
it for me but like
a human being as a human being
right me and sandy dan to her at the
airport today he was my opener and we're
we were like
just we played this game where i was
like if so-and-so died would you cry
so i was rattling off comics names to
him
he was like no no yes no no we laugh
about it
and he asks